[Music]
on this saturday night
mass murder in ontario four members of a
family
killed money does a lot of things to
people but
this should have never happened the
disturbing details of the crime
and the motive of the gunman cases of
cova 19
in quebec schools is it a sign of what's
to come
i wouldn't draw a parallel not all
things are equal and the added anxiety
for other students returning to class
plus holding the kremlin to account in
the poisoning of a russian
opposition leader i'm a pop star not a
doctor
and a pop star raps bieber subs in
for drake
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we're learning disturbing details
into a mass murder that happened inside
a home
in oshawa ontario four people from the
same family
two adults and two minors were shot dead
in the early hours yesterday morning
neighbors say they heard their screams
investigators have identified the
accused gunman as 48 year old
mitchell lappa from winnipeg who later
shot and killed himself
tonight the lone survivor a
fifth-year-old woman is in serious
condition in hospital
and as morgan campbell reports a
community is in shock
they gathered with flowers in hand to
mourn the loss of friends neighbors
and teammates killed in a mass shooting
in oshawa ontario friday morning
it's a tough thing you know it's
something you never dream you have to
tell your kid
of what happened killing four family
members and wounding another
is just it's unacceptable it's
unbelievable
chris traynor and three of his four
children were shot dead in their home
the mother loretta survived she is being
treated
in hospital the couple's other child
wasn't home at the time
i just know that things won't be the
same for her and i'm going to pray for
every night and
just hope that she knows she has my
thoughts police
say the gunman was 48-year-old mitchell
lappa from winnipeg they say he arrived
to the trainer home in his truck
uninvited global news has learned that
he is the estranged brother
of loretta and there was a family
dispute over
a will in winnipeg police have been
searching the apartments
where lappa lived to think that you
could just go
and do that it's like there's no words
to describe that
it's just terrifying police haven't
revealed any
new information regarding the
investigation friends say the family
played a large role in the community
chris was a baseball and hockey coach as
well as a teacher
at an oshawa high school it's just about
sticking together and
baseball families big sporting
communities big i mean the teaching
community is big
they would have sleepovers for the girls
their home was
the most welcoming place you could go
they treated everybody like part of the
family
as this makeshift memorial grows so does
a community's grief over what happened
friday it's a senseless tragedy that has
left
many with more questions than answers
as this memorial continues to grow the
city is honoring the family
in other ways they have lowered all
flags at city-owned properties
in memory of the family robin
morgan campbell in oshawa ontario
to the kova 19 pandemic now numbers
across the country are on the rise
particularly in canada's most populous
provinces
quebec released its numbers today 175
new cases and two new deaths
ontario is not far behind that with 169
new cases today
the highest daily case count since the
end of july
ontario's education minister is trying
to reassure parents
his province's back to school plan is
safe in quebec where classes have
already begun
47 schools have reported at least one
case of covet 19
since reopening as michael couture
reports it's added anxiety during a time
of year
that is already stressful for students
it's really nerve-racking because no one
really knows like what's going on
the normal stress of starting a new year
at school compounded by covid19
justine harris owens struggles with
anxiety and depression
and her sister has asthma so justine is
even more nervous
about going back i don't think there is
a solution that they can implement
that's going to be
you know good enough um at this time and
with what we know
and then that just kind of increases
anxiety more because like there's no
there's no solution it doesn't help that
both ontario and quebec saw a spike in
cases saturday
quebec's government saying nearly 50
educational institutions
had at least one covet 19 case in the
past week
when many students returned to school
ontario's increase comes the week before
classes resume still the education
minister
is trying to reassure nervous parents we
are doing
everything from enhancing cleaning to
obviously hiring
twice the number of public health nurses
in our schools
we've got a very strong testing protocol
an outbreak management system
leche says mental health is also top of
mind pointing out ontario
is hiring more psychologists and
psychotherapists to help students during
the pandemic
keep in mind the concern about covid19
is piled on top of the usual stress
young people are feeling
about heading back to school it's very
difficult to concentrate on
something which is already difficult and
that is the academic
dimension and we have this uh this added
uh
weight of of uh watching being careful
fobel believes it's important for
teachers parents and students
to give themselves a moment of peace and
solitude
away from the stress a moment where we
can reconnect
with our most inner self
and that way we'll find that strength
we'll find that that inner peace and the
strength
true deal with whatever happens that's
something justine harris owen did during
her time
away from school spend time with my
family
and you know take like really not take
the safety i have for granted it's
especially important to focus on those
anchors in our lives
during such a time of turmoil mike
lacrouter global news ottawa
in ontario a covet 19 outbreak is being
linked to two
church events last month health
officials say the miracle arena for all
nations events took place on august 16th
in toronto and vaughn so far 15 people
have tested positive
they can all be traced to the gatherings
the church is notifying members
about the potential exposure the federal
government is cracking down on americans
bending the rules to get around the
canada u.s border closure
known as the alaska loophole five
americans with alaskan plates
have been fined for violating the
quarantine act in british columbia
they were supposed to take the most
direct route to washington state but
were
sightseeing in vancouver four days after
they entered
canada vehicles traveling from the u.s
can legally enter canada but must
display tags showing
when they entered and when they leave to
determine how long they've been in
canada
the u.s is now dealing with new
outbreaks at colleges
several post-secondary institutions
across the country have been forced to
shut down
because they're overwhelmed by cases in
student dorms at least seven states are
seeing new spikes
and as jennifer johnson explains there's
concern the labor day weekend
could lead to even more cases across the
united states high hopes for a normal
college school year are being dashed
within days of opening
this week students were sent home from a
handful of universities including suny
in central new york
and temple university in philadelphia
kobe 19 is spreading out of control in
dorms
really hoped that this would be able to
work but
the data just was too obvious for us
students are violating policies banning
parties and the virus is spreading at
least 11 young adults gathering in a
hotel room doubling as a dorm room to
keep
students spread apart at northeastern
university in boston
were suspended within a week of getting
here they broke the rules and
was the consequences at some schools the
virus positivity rates are reaching
dangerous levels
27 percent at the university of south
carolina
29 at iowa state and if you're kicked
out tuition at most schools is
non-refundable my parents
probably would have killed me but
medical experts say students who test
positive for covet 19
need to stay at school to prevent
further infections in more vulnerable
populations
because what you're then doing is you're
getting an infected person
and putting them back in the community
to spread infections
on this labor day holiday weekend health
officials are warning people not to let
virus prevention steps
take a holiday the u.s saw a 22 percent
increase in cobit 19 cases
after memorial day and another spike
after independence day weekend
as long as they're following those rules
we're happy to have it
this holiday weekend several more states
34 plus the district of columbia have
mandatory mass
mandates up from 20 on memorial day the
battle to stop the virus rages on
as one model from the university of
washington school of medicine
predicts the virus could kill 400
thousand americans
by january 1st jennifer johnson global
news
washington the cases of coven 19 in
india have now surpassed 4 million just
13 days ago india marked
3 million infections which has put a
strain on the country's health care
system
in one state there are reports of
doctors so fatigued
they've abandoned safety measures like
masks and washing hands
prime minister justin trudeau took to
the airwaves this week to defend his
government's response to the coven 19
pandemic
in just over two weeks his government
will unveil its new road map for the
country
a throne speech that's being built as
ambitious and transformational
but at what cost mercedes stevenson
joins us with a look ahead to that story
on this week's edition of the west block
mercedes
prime minister justin trudeau has been
dropping not so subtle hints
that his government plans to spend its
way out of the covit 19 crisis
normally government spending is limited
by certain key benchmarks things like
the size of the deficit
or the debt to gdp ratio but sources in
both the finance department and the
liberal government say the prime
minister and his cabinet
are considering whether it's time to
abandon those traditional fiscal anchors
and embark on what could be a huge
spending blitz
that could ultimately change canada's
social safety net and debt levels
one of the people who will help craft
the government's road map going forward
is heritage minister stephen gilbeau
he's a former environmentalist and
greenpeace activist who has long
championed the idea
of greening canada's economy i asked him
to respond to the reports that the
government could
plunge the country's finances further
into the red
here's what he had to say clearly our
government is as an activist government
we've done a lot to help canadians and i
think the pandemic
has has shown us that there are some
pretty serious cracks
in our social nets um which is why we
had to
to put together a very quickly uh
the canadian emergency response benefit
which eight million canadians benefited
from
so i i think there needs to be some
some thinking about what do we do next
do we simply go back to the way things
were or do we try to
build canada better that of course
raises another question
just how much more can canada afford to
spend right now
the federal deficit is already set to
hit more than 340
billion dollars so i asked canada's
budget watchdog parliamentary budget
officer yves
jeru for his perspective it's without
the doubt that we cannot afford
deficits of over 300 billion dollars for
more than just a few years and when i
say
a few years i really mean a year or two
beyond that it would become
unsustainable so if the government has
plans for
additional spending it will clearly have
to to um to make to make
difficult choices and either raise taxes
or
reduce other areas of spending all this
talk of new spending comes as
speculation continues around the
possibility
of a fall election we'll be digging more
into that story and more of the top
headlines
on the west block all right thanks for
that mercedes
u.s president donald trump is once again
suggesting americans should vote twice
in the country's upcoming election
during a telephone rally last night
trump told supporters they should cast a
ballot in person
even if they've already voted by mail
go to your polling place even though
you've mailed it in go to your polling
place to see whether or not
your mail-in vote has been tabulated or
counted
if it hasn't been counted if it doesn't
show up
go and vote this is the second time this
week trump has made the suggestion but
it is in fact illegal for americans to
vote twice in the same election
there's growing concern trump's advice
could cause chaos at the polls
and potentially undermine the confidence
in the election results
to come the world is trying to get to
the bottom of the poisoning of a russian
opposition leader
[Music]
in bangladesh an explosion at a mosque
has killed at least 17 people including
a child
officials suspect the blast was
triggered by a leaking gas pipeline
it happened during friday prayers
sending dozens to hospital
witnesses say some victims rolled in the
streets trying to smother the flames on
their bodies
many remain in critical condition
the kremlin says it sees no grounds to
suspect a crime was committed in the
case of alexi navalny
but germany says the vocal critic of
russian president vladimir putin
was unequivocally poisoned with the
nerve agent novichok
the incident is the latest allegation of
questionable activity by the russian
government
redmond shannon takes a look at the
options in holding the kremlin
to account inside a moscow courtroom
a lawyer for alexi navalny tries and
fails to get the kremlin to investigate
the alleged poisoning of the opposition
politician
any use of chemical weapons
shows a total disrespect for human lives
and is an unacceptable breach of
international norms and rules
on the same day and on the other side of
europe
nato also vainly urges its longtime foe
to get to the bottom of the case the
russian government
must fully cooperate with the
organization for the prohibition
of chemical weapons on an impartial
international investigation
the kremlin says there is no crime no
case to answer
it's blanket denials echoing similar
reactions to other allegations of malign
activity
in moscow from the annexation of crimea
to allegations of foreign election
interference
and high-profile poisonings in the uk
all of which produced a long list of
sanctions against russia
but have they had any effect on putin's
actions
you can't really judge the actions his
actions and say
sanctions don't work because we don't
know what actions
he hasn't taken that he might have taken
if there was no
penalties at all bill browder says
expelling diplomats is
useless he campaigned for years for the
magnitsky act
sanctions imposed by canada the u.s and
others targeting human rights abuses in
russia
if the right people are sanctioned in
response to the navalny poisoning
that will have a a seriously crippling
effect
on the putin regime and the people
around him
targeting russia's energy income is an
option being suggested by some
german politicians they want to consider
the future of the almost completed
nordstream 2 pipeline it's being built
to move
more natural gas from russia to germany
economist sergey hestanov says these
high-profile
mentions of the pipeline have caused
anxiety in the russian markets
he says however europe refusing russian
gas could force moscow into the arms of
china
and that is not something nato wants
either redmond shannon global news
london thousands of women took to the
streets of belarus today demanding the
country's president resign
[Applause]
this is the fourth weekend protests have
gripped the country demonstrators
accused president alexander lukachenko
of stealing last month's election
earlier today
university students formed human chains
to protest the detention of their
classmates at previous rallies
but it didn't last long mass security
agents dragged up to 30 of the
protesters
into vans still ahead the remarkable
success of one canadian industry's
pandemic plan
early on the pandemic forced many
industries across the country to shut
down because of safety concerns
but canada's nuclear industry wasn't one
of them as our chief political
correspondent david aigan is here to
explain
the industry rapidly put in place
business contingency plans that may
serve as templates for others
in future pandemics david
documents obtained by global news show
that canada's nuclear industry regulator
quickly realized the risk to the health
and safety of canadians
if workers got sick at canada's nuclear
power plants
uranium mines research reactors or
nuclear waste disposal sites the health
and safety of canadians
may appear to be compromised if
operations do not take place as expected
by canadians
that was in an 11-page memo prepared
april the 14th
by staff of the canadian nuclear safety
commission or cnsc
but by june according to other cnsc
documents obtained by global news
it was clear that canada's nuclear
industry had rolled with the pandemic
punch
our licensees have actually done a very
splendid job themselves in
delivering their whatever
business they're in in a very safe
manner it was not just the regulator who
held that view
so too did operators of nuclear
facilities like ontario power generation
as well as the unions that represent
thousands of nuclear industry workers
you need to talk to your workers talk to
your worker reps
and collaborate if you don't you're
you're not going to be as successful
so the club it took some very strong
collaboration
to get to get people back to work safely
the key to the industry's success
using lessons learned from the sars
outbreak in the early 2000s for example
the industry recognized how crucial it
was to have personal protective
equipment on hand for
employees and as a result the industry
has maintained a
large stockpile of that gear ever since
really came about after sarge that
uh a need for something like that which
which would be required if there was
you know with a power outage or pandemic
or any other catastrophe
in fact the industry was so well
prepared it was able to donate
surplus ppe when coven 19 hit this
spring
and the industry appears not just to
have survived the pandemic but in some
ways
seems to have flourished for example a
ontario
nuclear power reactor managed to set a
north american record
for continuous operation without
maintenance or repair
david aiken global news ottawa
up next justin bieber lip syncs his way
into
drake's limelight
two famous canadians are finally even
after drake cast
a pop star in his new video i'm a pop
star not a doctor
[Music]
justin bieber lip syncs the rapper's
lyrics in his new single
appropriately titled pop star ten years
ago drake helped beaver with an
appearance in his video
baby the new single is by dj khaled and
drake whose only appearance
is dodging calls to film the video in
the united states
with the pandemic keeping drake in
canada he called in bieber
who lives in l.a and that is global
national for this saturday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
the sun setting over glassland
saskatchewan
we'd love to see your part of canada so
email us your pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching good night
[Music]
you